today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza yo yo you little dark
sharks you little sugar sharks you've
been swimming around in your own
sweetener huh you've been making your
own breath haven't you you've been
making your own breath haven't you will
you been a good boy or you been a good
girl go catch that frisbee go catch that
frisbee what are we even talking about I
don't know about to find out
I gotta let you know that this weekend I
went to Cabo San Lucas
Michael Mexico man our fancy little you
know beautiful heartfelt you know playas
beach umbrellas you know senoritas
LeMans
guitar oh you know pequenina violencia
somber re oh you know our beautiful
neighbors mihika Mexico and I look man I
look you know I got a little bit of that
flare in me tongue I got that flaring me
tongue you know I got that Nicaraguan
tongue baby you know I'm saying you
never even know I'll be like II wanna
maintain I just say something in Spanish
and next thing you know I've you know
all the girls they just whoa whoa I'm
feeling kind of sloshy down here in my
galoshes you know because they dampen it
up I gotta let you know that but and
when I traveled on the plane I wore
layered and layered as a clothing brand
and it's 100% organic cotton they're
made in America with American fabric and
they got that classic style modern fit
direct-to-consumer no middleman that
pass that savings on to their customer
and they make just the basics if you
want to feel comfortable and these are
clothing for me that's about comfort if
I'm on that plane I'm cruising I like to
be relaxed you know I like to look fresh
you freshy you know I like to look like
that fresh little you know cut a lettuce
that somebody just just lifted out of a
rabbits mouth and just set out into the
universe and that's what I get with
layered and you can go to layered USA LA
ye re d USA calm and use code Theo at
checkout for 10% off
that's promo code Theo at layered
usa.com for 10% off and I want to get
back to man I was in the beach I was in
the beach boy and I love being in the
beach do you get in the beach and you
just you know you have the you know what
happened I had the sunshine and the
sunshine felt good you know and it was
hot too and that's when you know
sometimes the sunshine has had enough is
the sunshine has just had enough it's
tight everybody's out there playing and
say you know what I'm oh I'm gonna heat
this thing up a little I'm gonna take
this thing to the next level and see
who's really with me because people that
can't handle it they go inside you know
they get the air-conditioner or they you
know some people will go inside and get
a um ice cube and you know set an ice
cube on the baby's forehead or something
to cool the baby down well they don't do
all that [ __ ] breath
some people go and they fill their mouth
with ice get out of here you wimp and I
never did anything like that man because
when that Sun heats up I say I'm staying
in the game baby and the water was warm
they had people boiling shrimp in the
ocean they had shrimp jumping out of the
ocean through through like a little they
had like a little kind of a coconut
canal they would just you know kind of
saunter through that and land on your
plate and they were cooked know what the
water was hot that's how much sunlight
was coming down because the Sun was
saying who will you riding with me are
you out because if you out get out but
I'm heating things up I think it was
honestly maybe 170 degrees at the coat
the shrimp came out they was coconut
they had grouper dude a lot of grouper
dude people were had a snorkel that was
the main thing snorkel fork knife and
you just swim through the water and eat
everything was though it was all it was
so hot all the fish was cooked
you couldn't find any sashimi things was
grilled up it was water grill
Royall everything was broiled that's how
hot it was down there meheeco and when
the Sun lit it up boy I stayed in it I
got sunburned
I got Sun learned I got Sun yearned bro
I was yearning for anything but the Sun
I took it on baby cuz that's where I'm
at and when I remember when I was young
I used to play this game did you ever
play this game when you were young and I
don't know if this was just like poor
kids played this [ __ ] but it seemed you
know we didn't have a lot of extra games
you know I remember we'd go over like
rich kids house and they would have you
know dessert like ice you know their
family beaten dessert together or like
we didn't have dessert in miles we had
here's what we had my mom said you could
have two cookies if you get three
cookies i'ma whoop yo ass so that was so
really dessert at my house was like do
you want to play do you want to play a
game do you want to play a game because
you could have two cookies and you could
be that good little Samaritan that good
little member de familia but you could
reach for that third little sugar in
Nuuk look and that's when that's
suddenly it was like saw it was like
like that movie saw you know it was like
oh now we heating things up now we're
playing a whole different game cuz now
you trying to eat a cookie and mom's
trying to hook nanny you know yeah mom
turning you into a [ __ ] that ninth
reindeer boy on Donner on Blitzen on ass
witson and that's it that's what it was
if you wanted to go for that third
cookie then you was gonna suddenly it
was a challenge you weren't having
dessert suddenly you was on a dangerous
game show because mom had said only two
cookies and you had decided well I
deserve more
that's one thing I remember about
dessert time but what was I talking
about
dang oh the beach sunshine getting
dessert
cooking let me think being at the beach
yeah I was at the beach and yeah and
then we had dessert man I can't even
remember and I wanted to talk to you
guys I know I was talking about the
clothing when I wore the I went to Cabo
San Lucas this weekend and uh and it was
fun man you know there's so many and
honestly I love being and I love being
in spanish-speaking countries I just
love it I really really do and it makes
me feel because I'm not joking when I
started when I'm I start to really
quickly I'm able to communicate pretty
quickly and I just love it and it makes
me and there's just so many good I feel
like there's a little something there's
a lot of a lot of I've met a lot of
great people that are Latino
I really have I really really have and
they have a special thing where you know
I met some some I met a man down there
who and I said some but I changed it to
uh you know because I'm trying to trying
to keep tabs on when I'm safe what I'm
saying is you know I'm trying to keep
tabs on not generalizing about those
types of things like I met a man and he
was born in California but he said you
know what he worked here and lived here
for a long time he said I haven't moved
you know I have family back in Mexico I
moved back to Mexico he said it's just
more fun
he said it's less stressful it's more
relaxing and I thought that that was
really interesting and he was awesome he
was awesome dude and uh we had fantasy
football draft and we had we had a great
time down in Los Cabos but it was hot
boy that sunshine was next level oh
that's what I was talking about sunshine
was next level and if you wanted to
really get involved in the I mean you
had I got sunburned I got I took it all
like a G like a champ oh here's what I
was talking about awesome I didn't think
my brain was gonna play you know and my
brain was it was just like it was on a
merry-go-round just now and it was on
and it was about to get off it had
almost given up but then it got back
around to where
it started when I was a kid so we get
that dessert right so you get the
dessert but then also what I was going
into was we used to play this game and
the game was called hot water and we
used to play this game at the house
where we would get in the shower and you
would turn the hot water you know it was
me and my brother and we were in there
and we was naked you know we was naked
man and we weren't looking at each other
real you know my brother I look ribcage
up that's where I look if I'm looking at
my brother's body ribcage up that's
right you know ain't that wild ain't
trying to be that good or brothers you
know I'm saying baby and you're trying
to be so much a brothers that we turn it
into a little bit of sisters so I look
only ribcage up when me and my brother
are doing you know experiencing
full-body nudity and so we would be in
the shower and we would play this game
called hot water and you would turn the
hot water and the other person had to
stay in it and then if they stayed in it
then you had to get in it take over
their spot and they would turn it up
more and your whole body was turning red
man your eyes couldn't even open because
your eye let your eyebrows or whatever
they was or I the skin over your eye
your little I don't know what that is
little vision nutsacks or something that
kind of hang down over your eyes but
they were starting to get so soft they
couldn't even they wouldn't open anymore
they just limp just hanging limp over
your eyes just like a limp little baby
nut sacs and you were just because your
skin was starting to boil and you would
just switch back and forth and keep
cranking it up until somebody gave up
and then that person was the loser they
lost but that hot water I don't if you
ever played hot water get in there boy
get in there and crank that thing up but
that's the kind of games you play when
you [ __ ] didn't have any money at the
house man
we all wanna you want to play a little
bit of hot water maybe have two cookies
for dessert be a good boy
act like you're gonna behave sneak
upstairs and into the [ __ ] bad
from and man you shouldn't give these
two little boys a shower that you
shouldn't have given us shower access
because we start playing hot water do my
mama come up sometimes cuz we'd have the
water on for an hour and a half do we go
deep we go all the way to the end of the
line until that thing was full hot steam
you go in the bathroom couldn't even see
where are ya
my mom furious and my mom was that she
would like trying to find us because she
cared to help us but at the same time
gonna whoop your ass once she knew you
were okay well in that the irony of like
some like mom's trying to like you know
check on you it's like there as soon as
you're okay
I'm gonna whoop your ass that was so
funny man just about being a kid you
know and about having that kind of mom
where you know they were just you know
just stressed out and overworked and
they were the sole provider and when
your mom had to be the sole provider and
kind of take care of you know be the be
the disciplinarian as well that was
while as soon my mom like I'm gonna make
sure you're okay and as soon as you're
okay I'm gonna make sure you are not
okay and that's how it was when we
played hot water you know it must be
tough on a lot of moms out there that
have to be the disciplinarian you know
I'm thinking about that right now all of
a sudden you know imagine that because
in your nature probably as a woman you
know I've never been a woman but in your
nature as a woman I bet you just want to
be loving you know when you want to be
you know you want to be caring and you
want to be you know you just want to be
you know sweet and and just hug your
kids and you know and just make sure
they're happier that's what you want to
be probably as a mother you have those
you know you want to be nurturing and
and then to have to be a disciplinarian
if you're a single mom or if you you
know something wrong with the husband
maybe he got hit by electricity or
something and he can't be active you
know or something happened to him he got
bent you know he fell off over
roof or something he's in a you know
he's in a wheelchair or a gurney some
people you see when I was growing up at
least people was in a wheelchair now you
see a dude on a gurney just laid out
completely flat like dude at least just
be regular handicapped don't go [ __ ]
go gurney you know like even people that
are like you know used to be when I was
growing up people that was just regular
handicap now they laying all the way
down when they used to just sit up it's
kind of ridiculous man like now
everybody's getting lazy even
handicapped people getting lazy or even
you know if somebody's paraplegic now
they pretend and they a quad just to get
that extra hit of money off the
government or something you know it's
just or just to take it easy and I'm not
pointing fingers at those at people that
have impairments or people that have
handicaps I'm saying it just at all
certain behaviors they affect every
realm of physicality and how in these
days you know I saw somebody does it
they push in there their family member
into arm into a um you know we was at a
hamburger Hamlet you know and I was
about to catch me a little bit of burger
you know get that sirloin hitter and you
was and then they had somebody pushed a
family member in on a [ __ ] gurney
like damn what about the witness you
know y'all can't even prop [ __ ] you
know uncle freakin cats in my er or
whatever the boys the dude's name is you
know y'all can't [ __ ] press prop your
boy up in a wheelchair like a natural
man I've got this dude gurney nowt up in
here come on I mean just be strong we
can all be strong even win their moments
where we want to be weak and we didn't
even go in with any intro music this
week this has been kind of different but
I think part of me wanted to get back to
my roots you know I've been feeling
sometimes like you know the podcast pot
you know the the listenership of the
podcast has been increasing and so part
of me I start to get I don't get nervous
but you know you start to uh start to
wonder well am i I just want to make
sure that I'm do that I'm still trying
to communicate the same way that I was
trying to communicate in the beginning
and uh and so you know have to be
cognizant of that and I have to be you
know because I want this pot like this
podcast started out I remember on the
hotline it was like if you have issues
if you have a problem if you have
something you want to share you know you
can share it and so I want this to try
and I want this to try and I want to try
and make sure that that's what this is
you know because it's interesting as
things grow they change they really do
even if you don't want them to it's um
you know it's like it's like you know
you always say like oh I want to be able
to I'd love to be able to perform for a
thousand people you know and then next
thing you know you're performing for a
thousand people but now there's there's
more people involved now there's
somebody that runs the stage lights the
stage lights and now there's somebody
that's you know backstage making sure
that you're okay and now there's
security you know with the venue or now
you're at a bigger place where there's a
bigger stage excuse-me got the hiccup
but it's like things change things
change and it's like so and I'm not
saying that those are things are for me
where it's like you know the security no
I'm not saying any of that I'm just
saying that you take anything you put it
in a bigger place you are you in a you
like I say a plant maybe a plant one
time is like man I'm gonna [ __ ] plant
you know I'm just a plant and I'm living
here at the Home Depot and I'm in a
little pot you know when they got people
coming by me some people they don't even
want a plant they just you know they
ducking off to text a side piece while
they wife is over there looking at
kitchen sinks and they ducking off in it
at herbivore section to text a side
piece and then they see me I'm just a
little plant but then maybe that plant
has some some some goals or some small
dreams and that plan say I'd love to one
day be out there was
some other plants you know I love to be
just have my roots just feeling through
some [ __ ] new soil and giving my root
my stem off [ __ ] lit up because my my
roots is feeling through new soil and
then I live around other plants and
maybe I live in a little you know maybe
I live in a median on between two busy
roads that might be his next goal that
plants goal and then maybe that plants
suddenly you know somebody buys him him
on the way home that you know the wife
from you know if she picked out a nice
sink because she thinks that you know
her and her man are staying together but
then she sees the text come through with
some titties pops up onto his phone and
now suddenly she's kicking that she's
kicking his ass out because he'd been
you know he's a nut he's not being
honest and so he's now he's on the side
of the road with his plant and he gets
tired of carrying his plant so he sets
the plant down on a median and now the
plant has its dream come true but now
the plant is like oh I don't want to you
know now I'm thinking about a forest and
now the plants in the forest right so
suddenly something happens there's a
plate tectonic shift in the plant
the median gets moved out into the you
know there's a earth Poseidon
you know belches or something and half
the world shifts plates or whatever and
then the median is shifted and
everything's changed and now now the
plan is is eroded down the down the
countryside into a forest and now it
lives in a forest but now the plant has
other different concerns and worries and
things now there's animals coming by you
know and now there's a you know the
plants outdoors it's not indoors at the
Home Depot anymore now there's weather
to be dealt with you know the plant
didn't think about weather before is in
a Home Depot you know it was just
watching struggling men and women duck
off to hit they side piece and catch
that titty pick or that deep pick or
that in bag pick because a lot of men
these days don't want to send they dick
they just send in a pic of a picture of
their nuts or a brief sketch of their
nuts
so anyway but I'm just saying like
sometimes you get into a place and then
things change and it's like I don't know
what I'm saying what am I
I hear what I'm saying is I just I want
to try and be cognizant of the fact that
I don't want this podcast to change
because there's been a lot of listeners
that were that are there from the
beginning and and I still want this to
be a great place where we can you know
talk about stuff and learn about stuff
together and I'm grateful for you guys
as patients and I'm grateful you guys
are here today with me and I'm also
let's turn back the clocks and this is
uh I just came from Cabo San Lucas so
everybody know a place that to them
feels like paradisio
paradise
[Music]
is that tiny sand who you know tiny boy
get it tiny
yeah man
[Music]
Tanny
we'll go to Paradise City
[Music]
as tiny sand whoo right there and some
of you guys know tiny sand who was a man
who out of the blue when his pasta first
started up he just sent in some music
and he's from the nether regions we
don't and I'm not joking the man named
spelled ti
n y SI in D H oh oh and dude it just
came in the inbox he said hey I love
what you're doing
I wrote this put this Diddy together for
you and there he didn't he played that
up and that's tiny sand whoo right there
with that instrumental hitter that he
made just for us in the Paradise City
Thank You tiny thank you guys for being
here this is a great time you know a lot
going on I was just at the beach man oh
you know when I didn't realize how much
I love just give him getting to the
beach of feeling that you know just
feeling the and you know what's funny I
was looking at the beach and I'm like
dude this is kind of naughty what they
do the beach just keeps kind of just
sucking on the shore if you notice it
like dang boy the beach is so naughty
the war the water the Nate there are not
naves waves the waves are so naughty bro
you if you notice with the waves they
just when you were looking at it there
it looked like they're just licking the
freaking shore like they trying to catch
some straight-up you know like they
trying to get that look like they trying
to get the land that just really bust
out and that kind of blew my mind a
little bit just watching that and then
just seeing like you know how they just
I don't know just the shore in the beach
there right there constantly rubbing
together and you have to think and
that's why I think it's just such a
place of magic because when you think
that the land land you know which is
just which is a amazing form and water
which is a which is amazing which is
the fluid bruh water is this straight-up
that's that x2 that's that extra plasm
you know that's that straight-up you
know that's that's that mother nature's
you know plasma water that's that X
extra plasm that's you know God's big
big big big vibe sauce and when you
think that water and Lander stir right
there in the ocean is rubbing against
each other if what afraid that friction
the the magic of those two things don't
the main things land and water and
they're right there rubbing against each
other creating it must be magic but yeah
there's just something magic that that
that friction occurs constantly forever
there's something I mean there's
something very magical but I had a great
time at the beach we did fantasy
football draft down there and you know
every year we do a destination draft so
my group picks a different City oh dude
so I'm down there I'm in the air traffic
I'm in the pool that you know they got a
swimming pool with the place and cuz we
just rented to kind of I mean this [ __ ]
was pretty seedy I thought like you
could hear a couple of gun pops go off
at night you know when some dude in our
group that's kind of rich he's like oh
man then I think that fireworks right
around the corner and I'm like dude
people don't die during fireworks bro
you know a couple you know a man and a
man ain't losing his watch and wallet
during a fireworks display okay so
that's somebody popping off that's
somebody takin what's not theirs there's
somebody cheating somebody out with a
little bit of that piece Tola that's
somebody using that gunplay but it's
funny how rich people always think crime
is like fireworks like Oh didn't know uh
didn't know there was fireworks tonight
I've been working too long at the UM I
didn't read in the UH in the newsletter
that there was fireworks tonight that
ain't fireworks player that's somebody
getting pop-up popped off that's
somebody stealing somebody's [ __ ]
stuff
so just being aware of that what else
ma'am but yeah I thought about the roots
I was thinking about the roots of think
about when the roots go through soil a
new soil and your repot a plant that
must be a crazy time for a root right
getting that fresh hit of those new
vitamins getting out there and then that
new soil doing that Ricci Ricci just cup
and dirt just fanned literally literally
finger-banging the earth that's what's
so that's what roots are when you think
about the joy when you take a plant out
of wherever it is and repot it into a
new place or into a new ground that
thing the roots just come out like that
and therefore finger-banging the
freaking universe and you can't say that
they're not that's all they're doing
they reach in they reach them for they
eat you know they reach them for that
mm-hmm they trying to cut that GUP
wobbling you think about that so if you
want to really you know if you you know
I'm not saying that you need to get into
pornography or plant nog raphy or
anything like that but if you want to
really think about doing something
naughty you take a plant and put it in
some new soil and then just sit in the
distance and have you a little bit of
sweet tea you know and just think about
the the lewd activity occurring down
beneath your feet and that's mother
nature yeah but I'm trying to just I
want to get back to the roots of what's
going on with this podcast and not that
we've been leaving them but it's like if
you don't check I'm just learning this
if you don't check in with yourself you
don't check in with what's going on then
it changes you know and you can lose it
you know and I was talking to to one of
her other producers the other day Chris
Perez and he handles you know he handles
a lot of the outreach he handles a lot
of the single moms stuff you know a lot
of the calls that have come in he's
handled for a long time and listening to
a lot of those and just double checked
and going through and he's done them
just you know a lot of great stuff for
the podcast and you know he's just were
having a conversation he's just
reminding me
about just about things that matter a
lot you know and just you know making
sure we check in with what's going on
here I do want to let you know look this
is uh this is not an ad actually this is
something this is a something I want to
let you know this it really just really
swaggy to me you know I tried to lose I
didn't trying to lose weight but I'll
try to get healthier a while back and I
tried a couple different meal plans some
of them are cool you hear a lot of them
advertised on different podcasts but one
that I found that really worked for me
was called catered fit and so I just
reached out to them and I said look man
I love I lost a ton of weight I didn't
want to lose any weight I was just
trying to get into the Paleo diet and
they offered it and and I was just like
I want to share people about your
company I want to share your company
because it's super helpful it's only
available in south florida tampa orlando
in southern california unfortunately but
they're hoping to expand and it's just
go to catered fit calm and and use the
code Theo von th EO vo in and you can
receive $25 off your first meal plan
I'll tell you the one that I did and I
didn't want to lose it I didn't plan on
losing any weight but this lost a lot of
weight so if you're wanting to lose
weight I'm thinking well man this could
be helpful to people that want to lose
weight I did the Paleo choices from
catered fit and and it helped man I they
send you the meals the meals are already
cooked it's already made it's already
they deliver them to you the night
before and so you get up in the morning
you got your three meals bang bang bang
and that's it that's it and my habits
changed my eating habits changed what I
desired of what was tasty to me changed
and I've gotten off it since but I'd you
know I think I did ten weeks and and if
you want to lose weight go check it out
cater fit calm use the code Theo von
SOTA sigh one of those things where it's
like sometimes you know we get presented
a lot of companies now to advertise and
some it's like nah this [ __ ] ain't this
ain't helpful you know we need doing
like somebody's like oh they're gonna
let you do a appendectomy through the
mail you know some of this [ __ ] means
nobody's taking their appendix out via
the Mayo bruh you know they send you a
scalpel and you use the scalpel and for
ten dollars a month in you mail it back
with a picture your the incision then
they send you what to do next like doing
wait enough [ __ ] three weeks to find
where the open wound to find out how you
could help me get my appendix out so
some of the stuff is just it's too much
what else what else is going on oh man I
you know I've been um I've been I uh you
know you we should talk a lot you know I
guess always talk about jerk
masturbation things I struggle with over
the years but I'd been doing good I'd
had excuse me I'd had two weeks almost
I'd had ten days honestly of know maybe
I'd had almost two weeks of no
masturbation's and you know doing that
self pleasure and you know touching
yourself with your own hands that sort
of thing you know
rubbing on your body until you know
enjoyable fluids and feelings come out
etc etc that kind of thing you know what
I'm talking about self pleasure and I'd
been doing self pleasure for a while and
for me it was always an uncommon you
know it was great but it whatever long
story but anyway I'd gone two weeks man
and ten days something like that and
then of no pornography I've had two
weeks of no pornography for me that's
good man two weeks and no pornography at
all and you know I got these blockers
now I'm a computer in my phone and I
didn't have that I don't think I had
that much of a problem with the but the
blockers help only one time in that two
weeks I've even wanted to experience any
pornography and I couldn't do it and so
it was just that one moment of okay I
can't do it right now what a saving
grace I'm glad because a minute later I
don't feel like doing it you know I get
back to myself but yeah it's crazy how
like the the desire to like do something
like it just comes in like an instant
like I want to not like all day I don't
think about doing the masturbation
think anything wild you know I'll see my
penis all day and I won't even I won't
even look twice at it but at night you
start to feel that weight between your
legs you start feeling that lurker and
it's like damn when my penis wants to do
something or something inside of me
wants to do something and that's when I
start thinking about you know doing self
pleasure or something and I don't want
to do you know I just hit the point
running it's just I'm tired of that you
know I want to get my Chi up and and
stay stay woke inside of my nuts and
inside of my brain because I haven't had
the healthiest relationship with it but
I'd gone two weeks and then what
happened was here's where I messed up
for me I didn't mess up overall I'm not
a bad person am I saying that here's
where I messed up for me was sexual
texting sexual texting and sexual
texting is when somebody who you all
know or maybe do know or maybe don't
even know send you a picture at a
butt-hole or day you know or de Kock or
something like that or they might draw a
face or put a little bit of a beard and
on the nuts and send you that [ __ ]
you know that nut santa you know put a
little gift next today balls and sinew
that you know you know in singing that
nuts and or something or they may dress
dress you know they made rust a vagina
up to look like a little while you know
like a little worm you know like a
little uh you know kind of like a little
bit of a kind of a largemouth catfish
that just put on some lipstick or
something you know people do tricks like
that with their genitalia and they sing
you the picture and then you get excited
so I've been doing well but then I got a
couple of sexual texting's from people
from women I think women I don't know
who one of them I think was this but it
might have just been some buttocks so
who knows what you know what I'm saying
you never know what conjunction junction
well yeah well yeah you don't know
weighted them cheeks boy they was just
fit you know somebody's feeling weak in
the cheeks and they start sharing that
stuff but uh but yeah
so next thing you know I got caught up
and and then I was caught up so so I got
a now I got a monitor that because if I
do if I let if I get say if I
something's gonna have to be weary of
that if I get sexual texts you know
visual type of stuff then that can lead
me to break my little goals that I want
for myself you know that I want to do or
not do and for me right now that kind of
stuff is you know I don't want to do I
don't want to look at pornography and I
don't want to masturbate just because
you know I don't want to do that dude
but you had a great time the fantasy
draft you know what I was thinking two
men I was singing this weekend like I
don't like I you know I never really
liked like being part of like a group
you know I started realizing that I was
thinking about it like I don't like
there's something inside of me I don't
want to be part of a group and I don't
know where that starts you know I don't
really know where that starts like I
don't want to be part of a like if I'm
part of a group then then I'm not an
individual and I think you know
somewhere probably in my life like you
know maybe when I was real a child or
very you know small Nino or whatever
that you know I felt like probably alone
and so I felt like oh I have to be I
have to take care of myself I have to be
in an individual you know I can't join a
group you know I can't and you know and
I struggle these days one of the
smallest groups I have trouble being a
part of is a relationship and being in a
committed relationship man I'm just and
that's one of the reasons why you know I
I'm trying to get away from the watching
the pornography and doing masturbation's
and they love that because I want to be
you know I think I'd like to be able to
one day be in a healthy committed
relationship and it's hard for me it's
been very hard on my saying it's hard
for a lot of people but for me man it's
been really really hard and the thing
that's been the hardest when I look back
in my life is really the commitment this
commitment
anything dude I never wanted to commit
and I don't know why that is and maybe
some of the listeners would even know
better than I would you know I don't
know why I don't want to commit you know
you know commitment has been the
toughest that's what's been the toughest
when I look back in my life line and my
timeline of being alive and being human
is just I'm taking the headphones off
because I find that for me with the hits
re when I put the headphones on I don't
I don't know I feel more closed off
sometimes but yeah the commitment I've
just have a tough time with it I think
is when I you know if I commit to
something then I'm I'm entrusting that
I'm not going to be the one solely to
take care of myself and I think
somewhere inside of myself like a long
time ago even if I didn't know probably
probably didn't even know that I did it
but somewhere inside of myself my brain
or my heart or both of them made
promises to each other that they would
never
would never like alienate each other or
something like they would never let my
happiness be dependent upon somebody
else if that makes any sense I'm trying
to feel this and talk about it at the
same time because I think that's part of
one of the things when I'm talking about
like getting back to the root to this
thing is like like when things get busy
you start thinking it's hard to feel
when things get busy
you start thinking instead of feeling
and and I rather and a lot of this
podcast was founded on feelings and
being able to feel feelings and and talk
about them and stuff like that and you
know I would just want want to be able
to I don't want to lose that
comfortability here and so so I guess
that's just something that I'm I'm not
working on it but I'm trying to be
cognizant of it and I guess I feel like
sometimes I can't I need to be thinking
and be quick and it's hard to feel and
be quick at the same time you know
feelings for me sometimes take a little
bit but I you know I think yeah I I
don't want to somewhere in my life for
sometime and you know when I was young
or some you know when I was in
adolescence or before that when I'm a
mom
the being my being was being you know I
was learning about nurturing or whatever
growing up that I you know my brain and
my heart probably made a promise they
were unhappy and they made a promise to
each other that they would never
would never let our happiness depend on
anyone but but each other but us but me
so that that way they would never be
hurt you know if I don't let you if I
don't commit if I don't go all-in then
I'm always saying if I always got a a
hook over here on the on the ledge then
I'll then I'm always in control you know
then I always have a way out I always
have a you know always have a waiting
I'm always you know I'm always not
I'm always not I'm trying to feel this
and say it at the same time I'm sorry if
I'm going slow here if I yeah if I don't
if I don't you know if I always you know
if I'm in a relationship and I'm always
I mean anything and I'm always [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] man I'm disappointed that I can't
figure this out and now I'm you know now
I'm feeling like I have to hurry because
because there's more listeners to the
podcast now than when we started
honestly and yeah and I don't like that
I'm happy that there are you know but I
don't like I don't want to not be able
to share what and learn about my what
I'm thinking about at the same time here
so I guess sometimes I'm not going to
talk as quickly and get things out as
quickly because then I can't feel about
what I'm saying and what I'm saying
right now but yes you know like Sonia I
don't maybe I'm not me making sense here
so what happened me was you know I have
had trouble being in a committed
relationship you know I've been in
relationships and I think back on
relationships in my life dude every
relationship I've ever been in I have
been dishonest in and now I'm going to
point in my life where I don't really I
don't want that anymore I mean I know
people are gonna make mistakes and
relationship I know we're all we are all
you know we're all broken regular normal
fractured humans we're all not perfect
we're all mortal mortal I think it's
called immortal one of the other we're
all one or the other and then we're
gonna do that you know but like I don't
want to I just don't want to be I don't
want to be I don't want to do that kind
of stuff anymore I don't want to be in
in a relationship for an environment
where I can't where I'm if well I'm just
so afraid of commitment that I'm you
know lying or being dishonest or you
know I mean I or you know cheating or
acting out there doing any of that kind
of stuff I just don't want to do it you
know because I feel like I have in my
heart that I don't want to be that
person but I think I get in
relationships and then I'll get
you know I don't want to commit that's
what I started realizing it's like the
commitment man the commitment is uh is
is the heavy part you know I don't want
to commit because if I commit and if I
if I go I think because something you
know I don't know when that kind of
stuff occurred in my life or you know
what happened but at some point I get it
was probably the CEO says he's
formidable years you know and at some
point I just was like uh no I'm not
doing that you know I'm not I'm always
gonna be in control of if I feel okay or
not that's what it is
I'm always gonna be in control of if I
feel okay or if I don't feel okay and no
I'm never given anybody that power
because I think when I was growing up
you know I don't know when but whenever
that before I even knew I was before I
even knew about it that other people had
that power and they as far as I was
concerned I guess they let me down you
know they let me down and so I never
felt okay I never felt like it was okay
to do to let somebody else be in control
of if I feel if I feel happiness and so
that's what our I'm at now in my life
and I don't want to be like that you
know so I have to figure out you know
what goes on with me that whenever I get
in you know how do i Fattal these
commitment things and and and one of the
things that I would do I've noticed over
time is if I when I start to get like a
like you know when I get in committed
relationships I don't feel you know I
don't have a lot of my sexual desires go
away when I'm going to commit a
relationship with that person
I still have sexual desires you know you
know on the same bra [ __ ] I'll eat
your stepsisters armpits out boy you
know I'm saying behind the post office
baby boy
you feel me I'll do that you know I'll
be that dirty dancer you know I'm saying
I'll pull that tongue out Billy Elliot
all up in your stepsisters armpits cat
dad
even after she worked a double over
there even after she worked a double
over there at the arm at the Safeway
grocery some same we know who's who when
I'm over there you know she doesn't
dampened up them you know them oyster
holes I don't wanna you know them
underarm them oyster holes them armpits
she doesn't dampen them things up after
working a double over they are at the
Kroger and then this daddy lino
Snapdragon with that Wow freaking you
know that tongue go over there and
polished them little bad kittens up so
I'm saying I still got them sexual
desires but if I am in a committed
relationship then I lose them and I
think part of it is because I don't
wanna if I get if I if I if I if I
nurture that rillette like I just
there's something in me that doesn't
want to connect like doesn't want it
doesn't want to lead things
doesn't want to lead a relationship even
further and connect even further because
I'm just afraid that I'm gonna something
I don't knows that I'm just afraid I
guess it's just fear but the crazy thing
is the fear is not even as if it's not
in my head really it's like inside of me
somewhere it's like my but it's like
just the parts of me don't want to
[ __ ] be like that so anyway so now I
got to start to figure out you know how
I can better get to a place where I can
commit to somebody and so that's kind of
summer what's going on in my life so if
you hear about me talking about things
like that are little pieces a lot of it
I don't know what it is you know I'm
still trying to figure it out but I'm
taking steps now to try and try and just
battle that kind of [ __ ] man
you know and I'm not blaming you no I'm
not blaming my parents or anything like
that like you know this some of this
stuff could have been their parents or
some of this stuff could it comes down
the line man you know you know I can't
expect my mother to have loved me
perfectly if somebody didn't love her
perfectly where's she gonna learn it
she don't just know that she did you
know so that kind of stuff makes me but
I don't want that [ __ ] to go on to Mike
if I have kids one day I don't want that
stuff to go on to my kids you know I
don't want that I want that [ __ ] to stop
here I want it to stop with me you know
if my family struggles with the prayer
this kind of stuff I want to because I
believe you can beat that we can beat
these things genetically but we have to
fight them so I'm gonna be out in the
streets man I want to be out in those
emotional and those are things that we
talked about and we still do talk about
on this podcast but if you can relate to
any of that kind of stuff or you
struggle with that kind of stuff hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three you know I'm
willing to explore this more you don't
have to leave your name you can you know
you know whatever you want to do but I
want you know I want to be able to for
us to still to be a place where we can
talk about things that we're thinking
and feeling and things that we're not
sure about but that we're trying to
learn and this is you know when I think
about dudes so this is some of the stuff
that's scary to me than anything like
I've you know I haven't had you know for
a couple years now I haven't had a
problem you know if struggle but I
haven't had that much of a problem
giving up drugs and alcohol but but
giving up but giving someone a
percent accessibility to my feelings in
my heart and that kind of [ __ ] that that
that is my Vietnam bruh
that sounds like the scariest thing in
the world to me it's interesting it's
interesting being alive dude it's
interesting you know it's interesting
being a part of this magic that's
created when the water in the sands
collide we had a lot of video questions
that came in I'm gonna get to some of
those we had a lot of audio questions we
had some audio questions that came in
I'm gonna get to some of those and I'm
gonna get to them right now I also want
to let you know about my date so coming
up we got Nashville we also have Toronto
but I'm not sure about Toronto so we're
figuring that out right now if you
already bought tickets you might be able
to get a re reimbursement you know I'm
just trying to make a femme I'm trying
to make this deal a fair deal and they
and you know with this group over there
and uh and so we're trying we're gonna
figure it out but I appreciate you guys
is patience patience so just hold a beat
on that and that's for the Just for
Laughs festival in Toronto otherwise
I'll be coming to Appleton Buffalo in
Salt Lake City and Washington DC you can
get those at theof on comm slash tour
tou R let's take a phone call or two and
see what happens man here we go what's
up Theo you crawfish King you owe them a
little snap as a boy them crawfish you
know I'm saying
crawfish boy that's like uh they
basically ditch
they're basically crawfish are basically
[ __ ] ditch Gophers more quick
question regarding working on jokes and
how comedians work together do you guys
brainstorms you run and pass any of your
friends and on the flip side you worried
about people ever trying to sabotage you
is there what what does the competition
look like there do you guys help each
other out or are there people that try
and break each other down that's a good
question thank you for calling man I
appreciate a young man misses and if
you're on the YouTube you can see the
video these are video questions that
come in
you can submit video questions through
our fan line
and there's a link on YouTube and iTunes
or you can submit video questions
through Theo van comm slash I don't know
what it is it's wherever the podcasts
are but there's a Dropbox you can just
send a video in and in the video you'll
be on the video YouTube you can see the
human this is a man he's wearing a grey
shirt he's got a beard and he looked
pretty healthy to seem like a healthy
man but he is asking us about comedians
helping each other there are some
committees that help each other the
funniest thing I find is when you let
other people make fun of you that's when
you can really learn some insights into
yourself and how people see you because
unless you know how people see you and
how the world kind of sees you then it's
hard to know what's if your perception
of yourself is a little off then you
might not be your jokes it might not be
your jokes that might not be as easily
perceived as funny by your audience so I
think a lot of comedians are helpful if
you ask some people some people are kind
of know-it-alls I don't like that you
know I want to be my goal whenever I
started doing comedy was I want people
to remember me you know I just want to
be able to share myself I don't care
there's a lot of writers out there and
that kind of thing if you're a joke
writer that's cool what's great but
that's not that's not my favorite type
of entertainment you know I rather see
somebody running from an animal that's
chasing them running from a dangerous
animal or every other see somebody that
is an entertainer that is you know when
I'm watching them I'm getting because a
writer I could watch a writer onstage I
could just anybody could tell the
writers jokes like they made them up so
I respect that the authorship of them
but for me I like to see an entertainer
I like to see a personality that's what
I'm saying and so that's what I try to
exude up there more these days
is to really just you know let my heart
get out through my work you know because
that's the interesting thing about our
heart is our heart our heart only has so
many ways to get out of us you know
because our heart really wants to get
out into the world and you'll even
notice that with you
blood think about your heart your heart
pumps blood away from you it plumps
blood away from it and that's love man
that's your heart is just trying to love
just trying to get out into the world
and that's really that that's crazy to
think that a heart has someone that all
it wants to do is just push you know
that love out into the world that's what
it does to your blood it just pushes but
then the blood only you're limited
you're limited within your body so the
blood have to come back you know you got
colder sex your arms and legs are
basically just you know long just basic
coldest sex but that's a good question
man some are helpful some aren't I keep
you know these days with storytelling
it's like nobody can take your away you
so don't be afraid to be you and I think
that just resonates across a lot of
walks of lot of spaces and life if
you're being authentic to yourself then
nobody can take that they can't take
your story you can't look at my story
and tell me my story isn't real and you
can feel someone's story when they're
telling it to you you can't tell me you
tell me my story isn't real don't take
my story away from me and that's one of
the things I don't like about Hollywood
sometimes especially being out here the
past few years it's like man you know
when everybody's you know these people
are making fun of poor people and making
fun of you know calling all white people
racist and calling all this and saying
that you know people from the middle of
the country or certain parts of the
country aren't worthwhile an don't tell
me that kind of stuff that's not right
because that's my whole life
don't tell me that my life doesn't have
any value because yes I'm not perfect
yes I struggled yes I've sinned and made
a million poor choices but I want to but
I'm not giving up on myself so that kind
of [ __ ] made me mad man so that's why I
want to get even more authentic
you're gonna come at me with this
[ __ ] and all that you know Hollywood
sometimes makes up all this [ __ ] they
think they're authentic they'd only they
don't have a they're lacking
authenticity
want to just be more myself because you
can't [ __ ] stop
you can't stop whatever you can't stop
authentic stuff and people can feel it
they can resonate it that's the human
condition maybe that's that hotline
that's that human [ __ ] wire bra and
you know when somebody else is on it
says look you get when you look somebody
in the eyes and you know that they're
telling you something you know they're
feeling something that's instinct son if
you need me I'll be on that [ __ ]
instinctive State that's the interstate
France stinks and that's what I'm trying
to ride right now you know I just don't
want to start astone want to get I just
I'm tired of being [ __ ] it but uh
let's hear more men another call that
came in here this is uh from the video
calls homeward it's gone
hey what up Co this is Josh and Emilio
from pop el California we have a serious
question to ask you okay this is Josh
and Emilio from Palmdale California and
thank you guys for calling these guys if
you can't see them on the video and your
listener an audio one of them have short
hair one of them longer hair they look
like they could be in a band they also
could be two dudes at work at Quiznos
but are the happiest Quiznos workers
you've ever met they seem like joyous a
young gent so onward so we were just
talking about the woman in Oklahoma who
got mauled to death by seven wiener dogs
a couple weeks ago whoo whoo and that's
gang activity mm-hmm and you think
here's the crazy thing you think that it
going after somebody with a wiener seven
of them went after a lady with no wiener
and that's reverse psychology and a lot
of animals we don't realize is you know
two animals they get together they might
have an idea
oh let's sneak out the doggie door three
animals maybe to be like Ollis you know
let's jump up on a cupboard and steal
grandma's chicken potpie for animals
they might be like oh you know let's
sneak out at night and get some [ __ ]
cocaine
five five animals get together five
wiener dogs get together and they mail I
feel like oh man this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
let's buy some peace tools you know
let's buy some guns you know let's buy
some advice I'm [ __ ] guns bro and
let's pop off baby but six dogs get the
other up like oh you know that's
embezzle money let's build a YMCA and
get donations and [ __ ] take some
money out of their coffers
you know we're so let's say we get in
swimsuits for the new YMCA swim team
but let's steal someone to add money but
seven animals get together and they
gonna prolly just take a [ __ ] down for
no reason what I'm saying is that's
groupthink that's dirty groupthink and
that's unnecessary man so if you see a
bunch of animals getting together and
you think it's funny and [ __ ] like that
and it's Care Bears and all of that
maybe it's not you know this ain't babe
pig in the city and other animals this
is seven wiener dogs getting who first
of all who even lists seven wiener dogs
get together and didn't think something
was happening dude I never [ __ ] seen
I've never seen seven wiener dogs in the
same state before so you're telling me
whoever owned them didn't know that some
kind of [ __ ] was going on that other
wiener dogs are stopping by to visit
their wiener dog or they're all meeting
up you go to the view take your wiener
dog to the park and you know one week
there's two wiener dogs there and the
next week there's three and then a month
later there's four and then there's two
you know seven two of them two aren't on
leashes and you're like well you don't
notice something's [ __ ] going on
let's hear more I'm sorry for getting
upset thank you for bringing this to my
attention and we're it's not funny it's
not as a serious matter and one of the
boys is laughing in the back and this
seemed like the boy this the long haired
gentleman onward so wondering how many
wiener dogs do you think you could take
say if they were attacking you like it
took I think seven to kill her how many
you take before they ended up taking her
life and thank you for the question man
I would say for I feel comfortable
saying I would probably say three if I'd
eaten recently and I had a couple
Gatorades or something on a table nearby
I would say four but you think about do
when it gets up to five wiener dogs and
a lot of guys out there but like I could
take all seven no you couldn't
no you couldn't dude because they had
and first of all a woman couldn't take
all seven and they got some tough ladies
out there so a man you get a look and
women are looked out for women will
fight to the end you know five wiener
dogs one of them's gonna sneak you up
and get you by the neck and the hard
part for some men is gonna be feeling
all that wiener against them and that's
the trick about a wiener dog is you know
they they get enough of that body
against you and it feels like big
wieners hitting you and next thing you
know one of them get you right up in the
gullet and you necked out and you've
been Wiener doubt but yeah I would say
four I think I could successfully defend
myself against four wiener dogs and look
I'm not trying to challenge any wiener
dog so if you out there if somebody's
out there caught up in the dark hearts
you got their training WDS and your
[ __ ] basement and [ __ ] and you've got
these little things going through hoops
and eating heavy treats and stuff to
make their necks stronger don't come at
me with that [ __ ] am i trying to do any
of that I'm just saying I think I could
take four thank you for calling in I do
appreciate that man I do appreciate it
oh let's hear what else man we got some
other calls that have come in let's hear
one man let's hear one right here sorry
homework hey Theo listening to your
podcast from the country of Georgia
alright from the country of Georgia Wow
thank you for calling and from the
country of Georgia and I'll tell you
this funny story very quickly I once got
propositioned by the country of Georgia
to host there it was basically like a
night of like a Dancing with the Stars
it was
a one-night thing I think a two days
show that would air nationally in their
in their country
and and I couldn't do it I had I had
something else I had to do but I was
gonna fly to Georgia and host their
national I don't a a don't even know
where George is okay and I'm not talking
Atlanta a lot of you guys are like well
it's uh it's just over there bah bah bah
damn South Carolina no I'm talking about
Georgia the country and B I would have
hosted their national all their
celebrities would have been performing
it would have been absolutely ridiculous
but I couldn't do it and it's one of the
biggest regrets of my life actually but
let's hear more thank you for calling
Maher is o side of the Europe far
eastern side of Europe there we go we
are answered homework went thank you for
the most efficient because I'm most on
fighting in addition moving better
already
you're welcome man and he said I want to
thank you for fighting an addiction and
uh and and that we are winning the
battle already homework sometimes I get
too upset and like a set of our life
being sober all the time so like like it
that happiness isn't really know we love
to hear from you what do you do to
recover yourself from seven acts of
depression you know sometimes there are
those days when you just feel like
you're just wasting your time
something like that will always thank
God but sometimes it happens thank you I
love you you're a great guy thank for
everything you do bye well thank you for
the call brother on it I didn't catch
your name at the beginning out if you
gave a few listening to your podcast
from a country of Georgia and you didn't
give us your name but thank you for
calling um what do I do
well you know I'm pretty blessed these
days cuz I know I have a couple people
but well first of all here's what I do I
wake up in the morning now and I'm back
on my gratitude list so I wake up in the
morning and you know I put my serenity
prayer into the world I write it down on
a pay
you know god grant me the serenity to
accept the things I cannot change the
courage to change the things I can and
the wisdom to know the difference and
sometimes dude honestly most of the time
whenever I say that prayer I can't even
hear it I just say it I'll write it down
and it doesn't even resonate I don't
think about it the rest of the day I
don't know if it comes into my life or
not I don't think so sometimes but but
I'm hoping that one day I'll have done
that enough that it'll that anything
that comes in my life I will think first
of all can I change this can I not and
then then I will put that prayer into
action but then I make a gratitude list
I think of 10 things that I'm grateful
for and they can be anything man you
know what I'm gonna get my bag right now
I'm gonna read you my list really quick
I'll read to you my one from this
morning this is this morning's so I woke
up in Mexico this morning I said I'm
grateful to have seen some of my friends
this weekend that's one thing on my
gratitude list I am grateful to have
been safe all weekend I am thankful to
be breathing today I am happy for my
arms and legs I am grateful to have my
family I am thankful for the sunshine
that's five things right there I'm
grateful for my ability to make and
and feel laughter I am grateful for my
nieces and nephews all started school
this week I am thankful for this chair I
think how I remember I was sitting in a
nice chair this is this morning I'm
grateful for my clean-ish apartment that
I will be going home to I am thankful to
hopefully be part of the solution that's
just my list man I didn't plan on
reading that but that's my list from
today so I make a gratitude list so then
suddenly my brain is has a little bit
more of gratitude so I'm instead of
thinking about worry I'm thinking about
gratitude and then what I do is I think
of three other people to call
and here's where I was getting to your
answer about the depressed when I heard
feel depressed you know I have three
other people you know I'll call anybody
anybody I think that can use a phone
call it could be a family member to
check in it could be somebody else
that's in you know one of the programs
that I'm in so I can check in with them
it could be somebody who lost uh you
know lost a job or somebody's waiting on
good news it could be anything just
check in with somebody who's not myself
but my problem is I am in the long run
I'm addicted to myself in the long run
had to take care of myself for so much
in so many ways
that I'm just I'm too used to it so I
need to think about other people
so getting outside of myself helps me
and so then to get to your to answer
your question brother what I'll do is
I'll check in so now I have people that
I'm always checking in with from you
know my morning check-ins that I'll just
reach out to one of them if I'm not
feeling good I'll also take action you
have to take action you have to take
action put your foot in front of the
other foot you know we just shared a
cartoon on Instagram this week from
Jocko willing who's an inspire you know
Jordan Peterson's been here he's an
inspirer take Fletcher you know you have
to stay moving and you have to get
vertical and
and you can always help others man you
know you can always help others and that
will make you feel you there's no way
you cannot feel good if you're helping
somebody else it's impossible you know
that's one of the gifts of the world man
is that that we can find the way outside
of ourselves by finding the way into
someone else and that is not a meat -
that is not a hashtag me - thing or a
time's up I don't mean fine you're
waiting and somebody else by you know
find somebody that's sleeping at the bus
stop and hide one of your fingers and
arrays I'm talking about about just uh
by just helping somebody that's how we
can do it but look man I'll let you know
this dude don't feel alone today because
you're in Georgia bruh dude can you
imagine dude in Georgia if I would have
been there on the television show oh and
here was the crazy thing they would have
made me learn to dance I would had to
learn to dance and that was another
problem I was scared there was like it
was like six weeks away and the lady's
like can you ballroom dance and I was
like [ __ ] yeah I can cuz I was trying to
get that paper you know stack that
Georgian you know whatever money you
guys use over there that Ram bought or
whatever it's called or young you know
that young dang or whatever so she's
like can you ballroom dance so dude I
had this I was gonna learn to ballroom
dance in six weeks for a net I cannot
even imagine how poorly that would have
gone but I would love to come to your
country one day and I hope that I get to
and I just don't feel depressed today
man you know don't feel depressed today
bro and I appreciate you making me think
about you know things that make me feel
better but I stay active I get moving I
get vertical cuz your brain isn't even
supposed to function horizontally think
about it when you lay your brain down
that's your brain doesn't work on its
side your brain works when it's upright
so at the very least sit upright and get
moving
I notice when I get moving everything
gets moving and off and I then learned
that I'm a lot more capable than I
thought I was but you have to take
action
you can't stay you cannot stay but when
I get out of it we get up in the morning
my brain starts wanting to do bad I
don't want to do anything he just wants
me to worry mm-hmm but I don't want to
worry and I beat my brain to the
Shh but thank you for calling man
certainly appreciate that let's hear
another call that came in the hotline is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three hey Theo just wondering how
much process goes into your actual
podcast how much editing how much
writing
how much prep do you do because you seem
to have a grip on the show really well I
mean I was curious how much just off the
cuff you do my name is Jason from Flint
hey Jason from Flint and y'all might
know my cousin daddy long neck is from
up there in Flint as well and that's
dirty water country boy DWC I would
drink your milkshake oh no I won't thank
you for calling dude I appreciate it
calling in Jason from Flint how much
prep not super much really honestly I
mean I think about it a lot I try and
connect with my feelings like today I
really made a point to try and connect
with my feelings before I got on start
the podcast you know and I wrote some
stuff down in the plane ride home some
things I wanted to talk about listen
through the calls and then some of the
calls I don't listen through because I
want them to be new to me but I do talk
with my producer Nick about about the
types of things we want to keep in the
program the types of things that are
important to me and the types of things
that are going on in my life
because I feel like if there's stuff
going on in my life and then he can
listen to the calls and is like oh some
of these things are kind of things
you're thinking about our dealing with
or whatever then you can and I'm current
on it in my own emotions then I might be
able to best you know be of service by
thinking out loud to other people that
might be dealing with or thinking about
some of the same stuff so that's why you
know I try and do that but a lot of
stuff I think I've just off the cuff you
know I don't want to be too planned or
prepared you know we do have now you
know our in-house producer Nick makes to
the sheet so there are ads so I can see
the ads right here and so that's kind of
nice just to have those
but I would say that that's probably a
lot of it yeah
I think that's it I'm gonna let you
write no no right now about this I had
this called SaneBox and dude I need this
man I'm gonna try this out I have not
tried this out yet but inbox mail is
inbox email is just bananas and you know
we had a mailman come on you know he
just called in a few minutes ago
and mail man that's the that's the
original email you know but um but in
boxing email is crazy and now we're so
inundated with the email that it's no
longer about responding to everything
and it's true you don't want to respond
to everything
it's about responding only to important
things the messages that truly matter in
SaneBox
SI NE bo x does the work for you
sanebox sifting only the important
emails in your inbox and directing all
other distracting stuff in ear saying
later folder so you know what messages
to pay attention to and what stuff to
get to later on it also has nifty
features like the same black hole where
you can drag messages from annoying
senders you never want to hear from
again
that sounds like something that's
amazing to me they also have sane
reminders to ping you if someone hasn't
replied to your email by a certain date
so that's pretty cool too if you need to
circle back with someone I am offering
to our listeners you can see how sane
box can magically remove distractions
from your inbox with a to two week free
trial visit sandbox comm slash Theo
today to start your free trial and
receive a $25 credit that's si any BOE
XCOM slash Theo for a two week free
trial and to receive a $25 credits
pretty cool
let's take another call that came in
here we go oh here we go
hey yo Theo this is a Sam down in Texas
I'm a big fan I list all your podcast
thank you for listening Sam
down in Texas homework relate to you on
a lot of different levels and stuff
we're about the same age yeah have a lot
of the same things going on that you do
thanks for saying that Sam I appreciate
it man
appreciate it homeward anyway uh so I'm
calling about your take on deer hunting
buddy as a lifelong hunter I think that
I'm both offended and inspired first of
all there's no share in a deer stand
with [ __ ] Stanley there's no
winger's involved in deer camp in any
way but here's what I'm saying is you
can't get into a deer stand and leave
your dick in the car I saw him saying
thank you for calling now let's hear
more I I'm I'm very interested though in
your challenge as far as the spirit
regulation spoon but what are the
regulations I'm a knife I mean are we
talking about a sword a pocketknife um
something between yeah you know you
really need to it would be good if you
could get back and let us know what the
regulations are on that because uh I'm
planning on getting that a knife kill
that knife still hit a dang boy dude
I'll say this man if you get out there
so the knife I think a sword dude if you
kill a [ __ ] deer or what else a
kangaroo a strong kangaroo you know or
at least a kangaroo that's probably 13
years or older nothing don't kill a damn
child kangaroo but um yeah if you kill a
deer with a sword bro or a leopard do
you kill a leopard with a sword bro in
the wild
I'll give you $550 bro I swear to God I
will if you kill a leopard with a sword
this goes out to anybody leopard what
else leopard and any other exciting very
exciting cheetah uh what else um a haul
not a hawk I don't think you can legally
kill a hawk but you killing a leopard
cheetah or other exciting animal with a
sword
$550 bra but yeah a knife I think you
have to you could go sword or you have
to go you have to go serious blade and
the spoon I get it the spoon is kind of
useless I guess unless you're really
gonna get out you know if you're gonna
get on its back and then and the spoon
is kind of messed up because you know
you you know I know I said just spoon
out of animals I you know if you already
get him with that knife
but I'd love to see that I think that's
the next step in hunting because here's
the thing everything evolves everything
evolves like a long time ago hunters
would make a trap on the ground and
think you know a deer would walk into it
and they'd have like an apple or a
little sweet tarts or something there
and the deer would eat them and the trap
would pull the deer up into the tree by
one of its legs and then they had you
know somebody would write something on a
wall and a deer would come over and read
it and then you know uh you know a big
hammer and anvil or something would fall
down and kill the deer and then they had
you know men started building deer
stands and spending time together and
then shooting deers from far far away
but now and look I respect that some
things are happening like they have bow
hunting now I get it
I'm not saying hunting is wrong hunt
brah Mel I'm saying I mean [ __ ] they got
neighborhoods over in the walls where
these boys are hunting each other
so you know hunting is something humans
prefer to do but at least four humans
are out there hunting animals I would
love to see that knife attack and I
think something too small a pocketknife
very very too much because you'd have to
how many get if the you know stabbed by
animal probably you know eighty ninety
seven you know eighty ninety you know 70
times that's gonna take [ __ ] I could
take fifteen minutes dude and that's
that's insane so what you need to do is
get something it's gonna be big enough
knife I would say probably eight inches
that eight inch blade but maybe even
probably eight inches 8 inches I think
eight inch blade or that sword
if you want to go with that long
two-hander boy now if you were [ __ ]
straight up you know your woods ninja
dude I think this could start a whole
new much more fair way of hunting and
and I appreciate your call man I do
appreciate your call and for making me
think about it and if you send me in
that video Big Dawg I'll send you that
five hundred and fifty dollars but be
safe out there I do want you to live
long I really really do want I want you
to live long thanks for calling um what
else do we have here
all right caller all right let's take
his call right here thank you very head
in the hotline home word hey Theo my
name's Josh calling you from San Diego
hey I was calling from San Diego a lot
of the guys I spent this weekend with uh
with my fantasy football draft force
from San Diego
um let's hear more I'm just wanted to
bring some up here in a situation going
on maybe you would have some advice on
this maybe some other people would have
some advice but uh I work as a graphic
designer
okay worked as a graphic designer really
fun job let's hear more and the company
I worked for I heard a couple weeks ago
they're going to be downsizing last
Friday the head of the graphics my
cousin M was if they could down syndrome
actually and I'm sorry I didn't think
I'm sorry I shouldn't have said anything
right there let's hear more work well
you said downsizing for people couldn't
hear it homework kumi-sama
on the on the download that I'm the one
that's gonna be getting laid off I found
out that the way this company lays
people off is they send them a test on
Sunday evenings mmm-hmm Sunday evening
they send it well look do it if you had
a long weekend and that's gonna be a
great text to get if he was partying all
weekend and you'll be happy to not have
to go in on Monday but the rest of the
days after that when you need money and
employment then that's gonna struggle
Tuesday through Friday and future weeks
and months I'm sorry to hear that man
let's hear more so here it is Sunday
middle e afternoon I'm waiting around
waiting to get this
text message from one of the managers
and that's what I already thought about
that like it's pretty lame I think and
maybe maybe how you would respond to
that I kind of want to say you know you
know I'd like to talk to them
face-to-face at least they could give me
an a perspective to let me go and look
at me in the face while they're doing it
not just in the tech man yeah that's why
you know you know what yeah it would be
nice if they did it face to face
especially if you know the people like
I'm not sure what your employment
structure is over there you know what
your management structure is over there
but yeah if they've said if they told
you face to face it also seems either
they don't give you two weeks notice so
you just like so you know there must
have been you know usually if they take
you know if they're gonna text you on
Sunday night then it should be something
you should know right you'll be there
for the next two weeks I'm not sure how
that's working for you but you know it's
just the the world we are in now it's
like that it's like that in a lot of
places and some of us we don't want to
admit it and I don't want to admit it
sometimes like I've romanticized a lot
of things you know I romanticize a lot
of things but a lot of the world these
days is al it's electronic that's how
it's going if you want to feel about it
you want to think about it you got to do
that on your own time buddy
you know people there's not as much of
the connection there and I think if
anything more than ever this is a time
when we got it it's it's about getting
back to the family structure it's about
getting back to the people you that have
to connect with you family because it's
you know these other other things are
not as much there's not as much
reliability in them you know there's not
the connection used to have at work
there's not some of those connections
anymore so yeah I think it's just it's
an opportunity for us to realize that
hey you know the people we care about
are not the ones that we're just gonna
you know we're gonna take it a step
further with them you know we're going
to connect on a real level
because other places is not they're not
doing it as much it's not as important
it's not part of the structure you know
people work so far away some people from
their own offices or even a country's
away your headquarters might be in a you
know it's just so far in so distant now
but it's hard it's hard to feel like
work matters that much like that like
they have any gratitude towards you as
an employee but maybe in a weird you
know convoluted way that that's a
reminder for us to be like well it's
time for me to connect and make sure
that I connect in a real way with the
people that I care about the most
you know those your parents and your
little ones and your nieces in your and
your animals and your siblings and you
know just let them know you K or look
them in the eyes go spend some time with
them instead of send that text instead
of send that birthday text to them or
instead of sin that that Thanksgiving go
surprise him well as last time you
surprised a family member with a visit
surprise somebody that you love you know
I don't know it's me you making me think
my brother's birthday is coming up in
two weeks and the last thing I want to
do is take another trip on a plane
anywhere anywhere I mean anywhere
but hearing you makes me think man you
know maybe I should just buzz down there
and see him you know he's going to be 41
you know I never thought he would be 41
you know and I just I don't know and we
weren't close when we were young you
know we wanted to be close but we didn't
have the emotional ability to get close
or the opportunity and Sonia tear I am
as an adult and I have that opportunity
and what am I gonna do I'm just gonna
send the text I hi I can afford it you
know I can I can afford that have been
years where I couldn't afford it so what
do I do you know [ __ ] now even corner
myself by talking about it and it making
myself now I'm already feeling bad if I
don't go but I'm sorry man I'm sorry
about the job you know and I hope that
you find some other employment he's
telling to have a really good
personality he sound like an upbeat dude
you sound like a guy who thinks about
things man those are some great
characteristics in an employee so I bet
somebody else is going to be happy to
have you and this could be an
opportunity a new opportunity just
waiting to turn around the corner and
say hello to you and I hope that that's
what it is cat daddy and look if you got
a couple days off boy you know what I'm
singing boy get out there son get out
there and [ __ ] am I saying getting
the dark arts but maybe [ __ ] stick
your dick into the gray matter you know
I'm not saying get out there in the dark
arts but maybe [ __ ] get out there and
see what's looming around in the shadows
daddy
do something do something unique with
your days off do something you wouldn't
do but take action move don't just sit
around the house and thinking about I'm
not working take action move you can do
something but I promise that you can but
thanks for calling in man making us the
making us feel like a part of your life
we appreciate it
what else we got another call that came
in here let's hit the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
thank you for calling
hey yeah mine's David I'm from
Sacramento California I just found you
like two weeks ago
oh thanks for calling David from
Sacramento you know I really I love
being up by Sacramento dude I am so
excited by the Diaz Poirier fight I know
that I think Diaz is out of that
Stockton area but anytime I think about
NorCal and them real boys in between
norcal socal I think about sac town and
I think about you know just some of them
real areas and uh man I'm so excited
about by that fight that I saw promo the
other day oh it looks so good
looks so good man I'm so I hope that
fight goes through let's hear more thank
you for calling in brother cover your
stuff I've been playing music for like
eight years
you know ten year that print are for a
little longer basically I'm taking girl
right now I really love her and I won
everything
Wow and that's cool to hear that man you
know it's cool to you you don't you
didn't used to hear that stuff a lot you
know a hundred years ago a guy couldn't
tell someone another guy that they
looked at you know there's a girl I love
her like an open forum like this so I
think as men we are evolving emotionally
in some ways you know maybe some ways
more than we need to I mean look [ __ ]
sometime I'm a little too emo out here
but thank you for calling so you play
music and do you see you play music and
you've been dating this girl for and you
love her home word she's she's family
we're in typing I love that about her
and I I'm just worried you know that I
and I won't be able to like pursue music
as much as like like if I get married to
her to quit because I just look like
being on the road and everything it'd be
really hard because I don't like I've
done a couple tours in my life and it
just takes a lot of time kind of can't
be that present and stuff and I always
just imagined it coming with me and
stuff I don't know I've you ever been in
a relationship and then all these been
moving around and stuffing like what's
that done to it and I think it's also
what do you think it's like that's my
head in the clouds here
anyway love you love you stuff but
you're awesome and I wish you did that I
said I want to see you out there you
should it you should come to Sacramento
I'm going to see Bill burr in a couple
of weeks and if you came through I would
totally go and I bring all my friends so
thank you man thank you for that I heard
you say love you too that Freudian slip
boy and I love you too bro
I'm just clowning with you there but um
but dude bill burns one of the greats
and you go see him and that's a real boy
bill burns a real boy man he's out there
and he's a real dude he's a loving dude
and um but he's a real guy you know and
I think he does a great job of staying
of being you know true to himself and
then I feel so blessed like you know
bill said the hey to me there's a second
time he ever said hey me when the last
time you know I saw him the other day
and it was like [ __ ] man I mean I was
can't even believe that that's you know
and even if my life ends the next week
or something that the FIR you know that
I got to have these moments were men
that I idolized and pee pee in Cincy
humor that I idolized uh you know said
help said hello to me and made me feel a
part of you know thanks for this Coleman
this is a big you know it's really first
of all I want to say that it's really
cool you to think about all of that you
know you're thinking not just about
yourself you're thinking not you're
thinking about you two together you're
thinking about you know the risk and
I'll say this in a moun life you know
I've been seeing a girl for a while and
I don't talk about my relationship or
dating and that kind of stuff on here
that much anymore on the podcast because
like it's not fair to somebody that I'm
involved with or it's not you know
because my life isn't their life you
know my life isn't their life um and uh
and it is hard it's hard man when you're
just face time in somebody you know it's
harder when there's temptation around
every corner and there is um and you
feel lonely easy because loneliness a
lot of times and if you don't feel like
you don't have a good strong sense of
yourself and and if you just used to
like when I get lonely then I'll do
something where you know in the path
I've made choices where you know oh well
I'll go you know you know meet a strange
woman or I'll go
you know I'll look at pornography or
something like that something to make
just and it's not even lonely it's just
some emptiness or something so you have
to be careful those things those are
pitfalls man because those can damage a
situation that where you really care
about somebody and a lot of that stuff
I've been well to work on some of that
stuff and I continue to but those are
those are real things out there and will
she want to come with you you know will
you can you still have your dream I
think here's here's what I here's what I
think I think you just have to tell her
these things upfront you have to say
look if this is I if said look I love
you I'm not sure if this is the right
move right now you know for us to be
together what do you think because these
are the things that I'm afraid of and
that's what I learned as I get older is
the hardest thing to do just to tell a
woman or tell somebody else if you got a
lover to some male lover or whatever
like that or you got it you know you're
not you don't like men's or women's and
you just got a puppy you know when you
and that [ __ ] just kind of look
each other in the eyes a lot but just to
say what your real fears are you know
and I should say when I get like you
know my real fears are you know when I'm
taking a break right now from the
relationship that I was in because I'm
I'm not healthy I'm not well I'm not
able to I'm not able I don't know what I
want I don't know where I want to be or
what I want to do and I really felt like
in my I was starting to you know affect
the person that I was date affect the
person and I wasn't evil I just I don't
know I got so many issues when it comes
to that kind of stuff but I think if you
can be transparent with them you'd be so
much more amazed I hear I hear from guys
who are very extremely transparent
relationships and extremely don't keep
any worries or fears or insecurities
that keep all that in the open with
their partner that they with their girl
or whatever that they
they find that that really helps him
shine you know but she sent minute she's
probably a loving person you can let her
know look at the I'd love to I'd love
for us to have a chance these are the
things that I'm worried about if I make
a wrong move should I do I let you know
do I let you know or do we like it to me
to keep that to myself
these are the real things that we can
ask each other and talk about you know
because times are different now it's
like you know you're in a real you know
like like it used to be a long time ago
you would travel but you wouldn't talk
to the person you maybe talk to him on
the pay phone here or there and you
would miss them and you would but now
you're like missing somebody but you
don't ever really get a chance to fully
miss them because there's so much
accessibility it's it's kind of strange
now it's like I don't know it's kind of
strange but I would say you just try and
be honest just be honest even if it's a
worry even if you're concerned about
what you ask might hurt their feelings I
think I'm learning more and more women
just want clarity they want to be
extremely clear and what's good what's
what you're thinking and what's going on
but I've had a tough time doing it man
I've had a tough time doing it except as
I've gotten older it's like I uh I kind
of look forward to more like the
FaceTime conversation and stuff like
that like I don't like I don't have that
joy of being out in the club and chasing
women that kind of [ __ ] man i ena I
don't give a [ __ ] about all of that I
ain't about that ending up with some
rapscallions and she's you know bending
over in the yard or whatever and she got
a mouthful of Nutter butters you know
her or um you know she got a mouthful of
those what are those Keebler cookies or
whatever you know them beautiful they
not there was Nutter Butter hitters but
they didn't other ones are Keebler's
with them little baby boys hiding
cookies in the trees she got a mouthful
at him you know she got a mouthful at
him chips eyes and she's trying to get
you to do her doggy style ain't no ain't
doing all of that [ __ ]
I mean doing all of that [ __ ] but the
dark arts are out there when you get
when you're alone you get offstage the
dark that's that's what's milling around
looking for you as the dark arts so you
better come [ __ ] correct with
yourself and your life let's take
another call here oh oh we got a call
right here it came in homeward and this
a man with a poodle right here in this
and this is really the dog episode this
is a dog episode here because they had
eight poodles got that lady or eight
Wymer honors or whatever schnitzels and
then they got this man got a poodle on
word so when if you're around like the
verge of uh or relapse what do you do to
cope with that you know what do you do
how do you oh and this dog just licked
that man when he said that sorry that
dog boy a thing hella gentle more solve
that problem okay if I'm on the verge of
relapse well I'll talk about that for a
second you know and I think he's talking
about relapsing on drugs and alcohol and
for those who some you don't know I'm
you know I don't do drugs and alcohol
I'm above about maybe 32 a little over
two years and I made you them again I do
not know I'm not gonna promise you that
I will not but I will promise you that
my life for me my life has gotten better
since I have taken a break from drugs
and alcohol and tried to find ways to at
least get a look at my own spirit and
see ways that I can help help work on my
own spirit and I couldn't even see my
spirit before this before I got before I
started practicing in sobriety if I'm
feeling on the verge of a relapse I do
the same things man I called friends
same things we talked about earlier when
the man called said he was feeling
depressed I called friends I'll go to a
meeting you know I'll tend a a meetings
or other 12-step meetings or al-anon any
of those types of things you know I'll
go to a meeting I will call a friend
the biggest thing I have to learn is to
ask for help that's the biggest thing
you know when this goes back it even I
mean this it's so funny you called about
this and I'm so grateful that you asked
this question because it's the same
thing about commitment it's the same
thing about me just wanting to be the
only person that's allowed to run my
show or to even know what my show is
you know I don't want to tell somebody
else that I'm afraid I don't want to
tell somebody else that I'm scared I
don't want to tell somebody else that
you know I don't worry you I don't know
sometimes deep down in me if I really
want to tell somebody else that I care
even
but I dunno
fact I don't want to tell somebody else
that I'm scared I don't want to tell
somebody else that I'm afraid I don't
want to tell somebody else that that I
think I'm gonna mess up or because if I
tell some if I do that then I'm weak you
know that I'm weak
and
and if I tell somebody else oh that's
not Adam as I'm saying that I'm losing
my feeling thereof I was on I felt like
I was really onto some feelings because
for me I try to listen and talk and
sometimes I surf over my body with my
like trying to feel something while I'm
talking and if I really feel something
like a feeling if I get a strong feeling
then that means that I'm on to something
it's almost like looking for gold like
running a gold detector metal detector
over mine while I'm talking I'm like
running metal detector over my my heart
and looking for feelings but no I don't
want to admit I was having more feelings
and I said I don't want to admit to
somebody that I'm scared
you know it's but I but that's what I do
now I'll call that's what I'll do but
now I haven't been in a severe instance
this weekend was one of the biggest
instances that I had I was in Mexico and
I wanted a damn beer bruh I wanted a
beer because I was there and the beach
and the commercials and the advertising
is baked into your [ __ ] bones and I
wanted a damn beer I thought if I poured
beer in my mouth that a million pieces
of you know beautiful vaginas and
Mexican you know crotchets and all of
that was gonna fall out of the sky or
something you know you have this vision
in your head all these tea dyes on TD's
and everything gonna fall out the sky
and land in my mouth and my tongues
gonna be all nippled up and everything
you know that lets a duffle just landing
in daddy's [ __ ] face hole but that's
not the truth you know and I just let
that kind of rot I told my buddy I said
man I really feel like having a beer you
know at least our belies dit you know
you got a little dog there I see you got
a friend in your video you're lucky you
got a cute dog and the dog is licking
your head while you sitting there asking
about this kind of stuff and that's nice
you have somebody that cares but that's
what I did I got to admit I got to have
to have say I need help
dude I don't want to need help I don't
want to need help I want to I want to
know you you know cuz somewhere inside I
mean he can't help me I help me I don't
want to need help I don't need you
that's what it was that's what it is
somewhere a long time ago
needed somebody and they didn't do it
and so I decided at that point I guess I
don't need you the only person I need is
me
and I'll be damned if I'm ever gonna
need somebody
I need in somebody
I'll be damned if I'm ever gonna need
somebody again
and so that's where I'm at man it's not
where I'm at but that's why I know
there's a lot of me is still in that
place I can feel that inside of me and
so it's hard for me to ask for help it's
hard for me to want to be part of a
group you know it's hard for me to
really commit to a group it's hard for
me to you know when my family's together
to stand up and tell my family that I
love them man but cuz for years in my
life I [ __ ] couldn't stand any of
those [ __ ] man if I'm honest am
I talking about right now when I think
back on being a kid I didn't like a dude
you know I hate to say this but I use to
have feelings like man if my sibling
passed away or that kind of thing when I
I used to wonder if I would even have
any feelings if I would even care
and not now now it's nothing That's not
me but I'm talking about when I was
younger you know I would be like man if
you know if my mother passed away if my
siblings about what I even care
and that's because I was so
was soaked I had so convinced myself
that I didn't need anybody but me but
now even though I step mad I don't want
to admit it but now I'm not afraid to
admit that I don't need I need other
people but that's why I still have so
much trouble committing come in a
relationship committing it every when I
look through my life I've had trouble
commit now into seven different
universities to get my degree I don't
want to commit I don't want to commit my
time I don't want to commit my existence
I mean just I just didn't want to commit
I don't want to I don't I want to do
haha I gotta do this I got ever want I
don't want to work with others you know
I don't want to but you do that enough
me just me just me no me I can do it I
can handle I don't I'll do it I'll do it
I'll do it I'll do it I know it's bad I
know it's best I know it's bad and guess
what you get exactly what you wanted you
get alone you end up feeling alone you
end up being alone
you end up being a lone man and if
you're not alone you in the [ __ ]
feeling alone and that's dude that's the
same yeah being alone and feeling alone
it's two different things you can be
alone but you could be married you could
be in a family of four and feel alone as
[ __ ] cuz you don't want to open up you
don't want to let people and you don't
want to admit that I need help i need
help just with this minute you don't
want to take your spouse in the other
room and say hey i just you know i need
help thinking about this for a second i
just need help this is my fear right
here I'm scared that I'm gonna do this
and then you're gonna feel this way but
and then that's you being brave now
somebody then put you on that puts put
you down in that moment or does that
kind of thing then you know who they are
or then you start you know you can start
to figure that out but it may take them
and used to getting used oh you be in
that way but yeah man it's been the
scariest thing in my life is to have to
admit that I don't want to be a I don't
want to be alone that's scary but that's
what I do man if I you know I had that
feeling this weekend but also I'll
celebrate sometimes you you know when we
did our fantasy football draft this
weekend I went and got a um they had
Corona makes a non-alcoholic beer called
Sara CER a and I went and got me a full
pack of Sarah's bruh did I had two of
them and I thought I was [ __ ] up dude
I started stumbling now I started
stumbling outside for fun dude it was
and we had a blast but but yeah you do
things select to open your heart up and
I see you got a dog right there and
that's a big move they recommend that to
a lot of people in sobriety get an
animal get something that you can start
to show that you love it
get something you can start to show that
you love it so that's beautiful man I
appreciate you calling we might uh what
else do we have do we have anything else
today um all right let's take this video
call they came in right here
hey whew and my name is Patrick I'm from
Belfast no nothing ooh Patrick and this
man is dressed up he gots on a nice kind
of a robe or something like a yellow
kind of golden ribbon around his neck or
something around his chest kind of so he
looks like a dang like he just he looks
like somebody won him in a prize in a
contest but this is Patrick from
Northern Ireland and that's the Pogues
country I think Shane MacGowan and uh
and onward thank you for calling Patrick
I'm staying home today applying for jobs
in my about my dress and gun and the
posture had been about the struggle
through one thing another enough fell
prey hard and hit the depression and
lost a lot of confidence himself rich me
I have to take a bit of a demotion and
work which is a it's a better first for
me thank you for calling Patrick I can
imagine that that that that's tough
taking a demotion oh man I can feel that
because you probably feel you know if
you especially if you were thinking kind
of you know decent of yourself than to
feel like all that other people don't
think that you're capable or that they
don't think that you're moving forward
it's got to be pretty tough man I
appreciate you sharing that own word and
having pride a little bit if I feel that
can be a bit of a blessing because I
feel that my depression has been caused
in part by I need to help people and not
on my current line of work which is
finance and oh wow yeah man you know
what's so funny is that I'll tell you
the greatest day I ever had in my life
and I appreciate you saying this Patrick
the need to help people the greatest day
that I've ever had in my whole life I
was in India and I was working with a
group and we were doing some we went to
a school for disabled children and we a
storm had come and really damaged the
place and a lot of stuff is all over the
ground
in this one area like a lot of just
heavy pieces of construction and all
that it and we spent the data's clearing
off their playground like and it was
hard work and it was long working when
he took breaks and like spent time with
these kids and uh and yet men at the end
of that day I felt
felt like a human being I felt
nyeh bleah that this is what the world
is about onward I was just wondering if
you can make any suggestions as to how I
can stay focused on looking for jobs and
avoiding procrastination because I'm
writing about problem solving one minute
and then I'm watching a face being
carved I apply Mo's on Facebook the next
I'm writing about problem solving one
minute and I'm watching a face being
carved out of parmesan the next minute
and Parmesan is a cheese it's not a
serial killer or nothing
that's hilarious bro I appreciate you
appreciate this you know what you can do
I'll tell you this point-blank
I'm looking at you right now you're a
happy guy
you just made me laugh one thing you can
do is continue to interact with others
that's what you can do keep interacting
get out there walk around meet people go
to the library I don't care go to the
coffee shop say hey to people find other
people that have law that have had a
demotion find anybody anybody because
you just made me laugh you can do that
to somebody else that's it so you need
to interact with others man you need to
interact with others and that's it
that's exactly what you can do and I
promise you that good things are gonna
happen to you I promise you a million
percent now you go out and you put one
foot in front of the other take action
you have to take action you cannot
there's no you will know you will
nothing will get better if you just stay
where you are if you just stay you know
when you get in a tough moment it's like
you can take some breaks you can enjoy
Facebook you can do this or that but you
need to take it you need to stay moving
stay in motion stay in motion
keep it cruising let's hear a little
more from you and a love listen to the
podcast it's really died they're
hilarious
it's place where people got to learn
something like remember who said it
maybe it was Jordan Pederson and but
people are being like stars of
authenticity and which is podcast have
some buckets fun so and so I say a big
shout out to my cousin
temmie I met James a hero both big fans
of the podcast along with me so keep the
good work and thanks very much mom
cheers brother thank you for calling man
cheers to you up in northern Belfast
dude I want to go to over there doesn't
it sound cool being in Ireland man it's
so cool you know I think especially
having a country where that seemed like
there's still a lot of like you know
country pride you know pride in your
country or like you you know to me your
voice to me obviously your voice sounds
unique even though in your country it
probably sounds normal to me it sounds
rare because it's a different sound than
I'm used to a different octave and a
different you know the Irish accent or
the Belfast I accent excuse me but yeah
it's uh it seemed like yeah just nice to
hear like an a it's like yeah I picture
you guys being in Ireland and you know
riding around on like little you know
Irish ponies and stuff and the ponies
have been drinking at the bar and so
they're late and you guys are just
standing outside and you're angry you
know and you're like whoa where's the
horsies and and the horses finally show
up but they're late because they've been
drinking
you know and they've been watching the
foot tea on telly and um and finally you
guys get on the horses or the ponies
they're actually ponies and you just go
right back to the bar and I'm like
that's awesome dude but I appreciate you
guys support I appreciate the nice words
but that's what you can do just stay
busy you know at the end there you
mentioned to your friends it's like
you're not thinking about yourself
you're gonna be fine you know you just
stay busy and keep thinking about others
dude and you're gonna do great but stay
active in it and we can't get caught up
in it you know it's like we have to be
careful when we are doing stuff that we
don't even when we start to do stuff
that we don't think it's about us and we
stay true to we've we make sure that we
touching base with our roots we make
sure that we find people who we can
connect with and ask for help
you know even if we're just asking for
help to like just make sure that we're
hey am i doing this okay
do I seem okay you know maybe ask
somebody do you know that I love you
like when was the last time you asked
akka you know you know I remember one
thing that makes me sad something I'm
not sad but like I when I was really
struggling with like having like any
feelings like I used to like really
struggle with having like any emotions
at all I would have a ton of thoughts
but having emotions now I didn't know
who I was I didn't know at all I knew
I'd been alive and I and I knew you know
had a lot of experiences and I
remembered many of them just like anyone
else but I didn't know who I was and I
used to ask my best friend I'm like Who
am I like do you have any or one of my
best friend like do that kid just how am
I I can you tell me anything about
myself because I was so out of touch of
my feelings you know your feelings are
really where you learn who you are and
if we're fortunate enough to really you
know
really connect with other people I think
we'll find that we're probably good or a
good person you know that we mean well
but yeah look I appreciate it man
I appreciate you checking in Patrick and
if I had a [ __ ] job I'd give it to
you you know I don't know what I do for
of if they have a Belfast person but I
would give you a job man but I think
we'll close up right there man we had um
you know Dee Snider hit the hotline on
put it we'll put his call on next week
we've had some other calls that came in
we just couldn't get to everything but I
appreciate it appreciate you guys you
know like and look sometimes I'll talk
about Sheila's pocket might not make any
sense to anybody
oh well you know I'm you know all I can
do is make my effort but tiny Sandhu who
is you that's the craziest thing is we
never even seen a picture of him we
never even seen a picture of that Magic
Man mr. tiny sand who isn't that crazy
he's got to keep making it worse all we
can do we got to keep making it but I
want to think we had a lot of great
calls man the musician that called in on
you know the wiener dog there's killers
dogs everybody everybody that called in
we'll get to some of the rest of it this
week and just keep making it man you
don't have to solve it all today you do
not have to solve the world today just
remember that and if you don't know
what's going on if you don't if we don't
know where we are we can ask other
people for help you know
if you're not sure how other people feel
you can ask them like you know do you
know that I care do you know that I do
care do you know that I love you do you
know that this do you know that that and
ask them if they don't then you can talk
about it and that's how we that's how
you and me learn you know I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about I'm not
preaching at you I'm just trying to talk
sometimes so that I can feel something
myself on the way out man this band is
coming to Los Angeles September 7th
they'll be at the mint
they'll be at the mint here in Los
Angeles and I may be there I don't know
though know may or may not my brother's
birthday is the next day and I'm gonna
try to make it home for that but this uh
we're just making a man that's all we're
doing you guys be good to yourselves you
probably you probably deserve it
this is Bishop Gunn with making it and
they will be at the mint on September
7th
I've seen home in about a hundred days I
can almost hear mama bleep for my
restless soul and I ain't made a dollar
night spell but where it's going ain't
you me and I still get wet
you
[Music]
making wrong bacon
you
making it baby
most all of my plans slip right through
my hands and rock up next to me poking
on
if their spiral wasn't our glance I'm
sailing I'm about an hour past
oh man it's a line right there
but how
[Music]
making good time
mr. gun
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
wow man that fits right in between the
lines that I've crossed and the friends
that I've lost but I'm in pretty good
shape for the shape that I'm in just
really
[Music]
full-circle man you guys be good to
yourselves dude
Buckingham
[Music]